merci
pour tout ce que vous avez fait merci
pour tout ce que vous avez donné à notre
pays vous êtes invincible
l'armée la population la société civile
vous êtes les représentants
notre peuple vous êtes nous partenaires
vous êtes nos amis donc merci à tous je
vous dis du fond du coeur merci je suis
convaincu que vous ne savez pas encore
dans quelle mesure vous avez contribué
à notre victoire mais vous allez petit à
petit comprendre la valeur de votre
travail encore une fois merci ce que
vous avez fait pour l'Ukraine le monde
entier maintenant connaît notre pays et
notre lutte le monde
n'oublie pas le crâne vous combattez la
lassitude et cela nous aide en retour à
devenir invincible
c'est moi cette année a été extrêmement
difficile mais nous sommes restés
invincibles et en partie grâce à vous
je tiens également à remercier ceux
d'entre vous qui ne sont plus parmi nous
et qui ne le seront plus jamais je pense
aux journalistes hommes et femmes qui
sont morts durant cette guerre qui ont
donné leur vie pour notre pays
il y a un certain nombre de personnes de
votre profession
qui l'ont fait et je tiens
à honorer vos confrères et concerts qui
ont donné leur vie en service au service
de notre pays
observons s'il vous plaît minute de
silence
merci et à demain
[Musique]
si nous partenaires restent unis
derrière notre victoire cette victoire
sera une victoire de nos valeurs
tout ce que nous avons promis ne restera
pas d'être morte nous comptons sur nos
partenaires nous savons
nous savons pouvoir compter sur nos
partenaires et nous allons faire en
partenariat avec eux nos devoirs nous
allons faire ce qu'il nous demande
la victoire est au bout du chemin j'en
suis absolument convaincu nous avons
tout ce qu'il faut pour cela la
détermination la conviction
la force de travail de nos diplomates
votre travail vous êtes resté unis dans
cette invasion et vous avez participé à
la communication nécessaire à notre pays
aucun pays ne peut être isolé
dans le cadre dans le cadre d'une
agression aucun pays ne peut aucun pays
ne peut survivre dans un cadre pareil si
les seuls sauf peut-être les États-Unis
mais ça n'est pas leur cas la Fédération
de Russie est seule isolée l'Ukraine ne
l'est pas elle a des amis des
partenaires déterminés pourquoi car nos
partenaires ne sont pas sont déterminés
à ne pas laisser cette agression impunie
et
se propager Poutine veut tout il veut la
Crimée il veut tomber il veut l'Ukraine
nous savons ce que veut est-ce que
veulent les élites militaires et
politiques de la Russie il faut que nous
continuons à travailler tous ensemble
pour atteindre la victoire car la vérité
est absolument de notre côté
nous le faisons pour notre pays et pour
nos enfants
c'est une horreur que de les perdre dans
le cadre de ce conflit
et comme vous le savez les Russes
ne prennent
ne prennent aucune mesure pour éviter de
bombarder les enfants
merci merci pour l'exemple
d'invosité que vous donnez nous croyons
tous nous avons tous foi en la victoire
nous avons entendu un certain nombre
d'experts internationaux dire que cette
guerre est en train de devenir une
guerre d'attrition
nécessite davantage de ressources afin
de pouvoir vaincre sur le champ de
bataille nous ne devons pas il faut donc
négocier comment selon vous cette guerre
va-t-elle être gagnée concrètement
je ne pense pas la théorie de la
victoire nous sommes dans l'action nous
faisons concrètement ce qui est
nécessaire de faire le crâne à lancer
un projet un plan de paix Projet de paix
dont nous avons absolument besoin nous
l'avons proposé au G20
nous avons demandé à ce qu'il y a un G19
c'est-à-dire sans la Russie mais malgré
tout malgré la présence de la Russie
nous avons présenté notre plan de paix
crise à une influence existentielle sur
notre sécurité à cause de l'agression
russe vous savez aussi
quels sont les attaques que la Russie
commet contre nos centrales nucléaires
par exemple
vous connaissez également les effets
pour la sécurité mondiale de la crise
alimentaire engendrée par l'agression
nous avons présenté un plan nous avons
proposé des mesures il y a un intérêt au
niveau international pour la pour la
mise en place tous ces de ce plan de
paix que nous avons proposé
hier soir
141 nations des Nations Unies ont
soutenu la résolution que nous avons
proposé cela signifie que la majorité de
la communauté internationale est
derrière nous et nous souhaitons
que les résultats
suivent nous organiserons prochainement
davantage d'initiative diplomatique en
particulier un sommet de la paix
beaucoup de pays seront représentés je
travaille avec nos équipes avec nos
partenaires pour que cela ait lieu
il n'y aura pas nous n'aurons pas le
soutien que de nos partenaires
stratégiques qui nous soutiennent depuis
les premières heures de cette guerre
justifiée nous bénéficions également
du soutien
d'un certain nombre d'autres pays
d'autres continents
je fais pour cela tout ce qui est
nécessaire
en particulier en ce qui concerne les
continents africains je souhaite je
désire que c'est
que les africains soient présents à ce
sommet ainsi que l'Inde et la Chine
notre volonté est de les convaincre
autant qu'il est possible nous
souhaitons voir autant de pays se
rallier à la résolution
de l'ONU qu'il est possible
dans le cadre de la charte de l'ONU dans
le cadre du droit des peuples à vivre
librement et sans agression notre plan
de paix est très démocratique tout ce
que nous faisons en Ukraine est
maintenant démocratique et tout est
assez simple
nous demandons simplement aux autres
Nations Unies de nous soutenir nous une
nation agressée
et je pense que tout le monde peut être
d'accord avec au moins un point de notre
plan de paix c'est bien sûr la
sécurisation des sites nucléaires
nous avons présenté ce plan de punk nous
avons présenté les détails nous avons
présenté les conclusions et ce planter
va dans le sens de l'intérêt de
l'ensemble des nations du monde
ce plan de paix également vise à
garantir sur le long terme notre
sécurité cela aurait été une influence
pour l'ensemble du monde nous comprenons
ce qui est en jeu nous comprenons
l'importance de la réalisation de la
mise en œuvre de ces points
nous sommes nous travaillons à la
résolution diplomatique de cette guerre
je tiens à le dire mais pour pouvoir le
faire un diplomatiquement il faut que
autant de pays que possible sera lié
aux différents points du plan de chèque
nous avons présenté
une question des médias mexicains
il faut probablement bien expliquer ce
qu'est la guerre ce que sont nos pertes
on ne perd pas que du territoire
j'ai également des gens beaucoup de gens
qui meurent quand vous n'êtes pas en
guerre quand vous n'avez pas éprouvé la
guerre vous n'avez pas vous ne pouvez
pas comprendre
la douleur la souffrance qui va avec la
guerre c'est très difficile à décrire
mais c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
travaillons en permanence avec vous
pour vous compreniez ce qu'est la guerre
il y a
vous pouvez peut-être être à distance et
vous demander si nos
initiatives sont pertinentes mais nous
initiative vont dans le sens de mettre
fin à toutes ces souffrances tous ces
viols à tous ces meurtres à tous ces
assassinats à toutes ces destructions
c'est la raison du travail que nous
faisons
journaliste de Neste il doit jusqu'à
avons-nous besoin des initiatives de la
fédération de Rossi avons-nous besoin de
ce que fait la Fédération de Russie dans
le monde je ne crois pas
sur quoi nous travaillons au niveau
diplomatique faire comprendre
ce que fait la Russie d'où cette
révolution à l'ONU d'où les sangles et
les 141 voix en notre faveur à l'ONU
l'objectif une fine et de garantir et de
sauver la souveraineté de notre pays
beaucoup de pays affirme que notre que
la Fédération de Russie doit quitter
notre territoire et pour cela nous
travaillons avec beaucoup de partenaires
il faut que nous inventions il faut que
nous avions et que nous nous adressons
également à d'autres partenaires comme
les partenaires du continent africain je
crois je peux dire que nous les avons
parfois négligé par le passé et cela a
été une erreur considérable c'est
pourquoi lui créer un adopté un
programme diplomatique spécifiquement
destiné à expliquer et à convaincre sur
le continent africain je pense également
à notre initiative green
visant à assurer la stabilité
alimentaire du monde mais il y a
également d'autres initiatives nous le
faisons au quotidien nous investissons
au quotidien pour la paix nous avons
perdu du temps il faut le rattraper
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui nous nous
battons nous nous battons pour notre
indépendance et pour notre survie
à l'époque
nous ne sommes pas assez appuyés
sur les pays africains et nous avons
manqué de leadership nous sommes en
train de
combler ce manque nous parlons au pays
africain au pays d'Amérique latine leur
soutien nous est essentiel nous est très
important je souhaite qu'il y ait un
sommet des
sommet entre l'Ukraine avec l'Ukraine
les pays d'Amérique latines et les pays
africains je ne veux pas quitter mon
pays mais je serais disposé à quitter
Kiev pour me rendre à se mettre de cette
nature car ce serait initiative très
importante
pour organiser un sommet de cette nature
et pour convaincre de la nécessité d'un
seul Thomas c'est soit à quoi nous
aurions dû travailler pendant 30 ans
mais malheureusement c'est la guerre qui
nous a poussé vers les pays de ces
continents
c'est l'agression d'un de nos voisins
qui nous a poussé à faire cela
c'est la Russie avec son désert de nous
détruire intégralement
ce que nous faisons
le passé et le passé mais c'est l'avenir
qui compte nous avons besoin du soutien
de ces continents pour vaincre et nous
travaillons dans ce sens nous sommes
dans un dialogue juste et franc avec ces
pays
nous avons travaillé pour unir les pays
européens
dans le soutien de notre cause mais nous
tentons également de venir davantage de
pays c'était une autre nous avons réussi
à organiser un certain nombre nous
voulons que des que les pays du monde ne
soient pas neutres
je crois que c'est très important et ce
sur quoi nous travaillons avec beaucoup
d'attention beaucoup d'efforts au
quotidien pourquoi car la victoire sur
le champ de bataille
permet de donner un à nos partenaires
des assurances personne ne vole au
secours de la défaite
c'est pourquoi la victoire militaire
nous permet d'être dans de bonnes
positions sur le champ de bataille
d'être en position de force sur le champ
de bataille diplomatique afin de nous
garantir du soutien
[Musique]
question
complexe un point
important sur la justice
nous avons présenté un plan de paix vous
le savez
nous pensons aux enjeux que vous avez
évoqué quant aux institutions et aux
tribunaux en particulier
tout découle du soutien politique et de
l'unité politique que nous pouvons
engendrer
ce soutien n'est peut-être pas universel
mais plateforme de signature
n'est jamais universellement salué
l'objectif est de l'unifier autant de
pays que possible derrière cette terre
cette création d'un tribunal mis en
place pour les crimes commis par la
Russie durant cette agression
nous travaillons également à la mise en
place d'un mécanisme spécial visant à
compenser les dégâts
engendrés par la Russie sur notre
territoire
nous travaillons sur sur ces enjeux
monsieur coulibat ses équipes le
procureur général
ukrainien travaille dans ce sens nous
travaillons tous dans ce sens chaque
jour
c'est un mécanisme fort complexe je ne
les nerve pas et pour dire vrai
la plupart des pays ont peur
peur de mettre en place cette tribunaux
peur
de l'envisager et on peut aisément qu'on
prenne pourquoi car ils peuvent un
moment ou un autre et être soumis
mais
à ma place mon rôle est de générer un
consensus et d'unifier
au niveau des Nations Unies
les leaders politiques
d'engager leur pays dans ce sens nous
ferons en sorte
d'avancer sur ce sujet et d'engranger
des soutiens nous avons besoin
d'experts nous avons besoin des pays qui
peuvent jouer un rôle important dans la
mise en place d'un tribunal de cette
nature nous travaillons avec le Premier
ministre néerlandais mais également avec
d'autres pays nous travaillons
à la mise en place d'un mécanisme de
compensation et un certain nombre de
choses bougent aux Etats-Unis mais
également dans les pays baltes le trio
Balt et la Pologne nous soutiennent
dans tout ce que nous entreprenons
cela étant dit
nous travaillons comme je l'ai dit sur
cette enjeu qui est fort compliqué
pourquoi
pour revenir à la deuxième part de votre
question la deuxième partie de votre
question car les institutions qui
existent ont été créés il y a longtemps
institution qui
n'ont pas encore été confrontés à la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes il
n'y a pas cette expérience
il y a un système bureaucratique qui
n'est pas en mesure de fournir des
réponses claires aux questions que nous
posons pour les réparations et pour la
justice dont nous avons besoin
nos citoyens ont été assassinés
nos villes détruites tout cela demande
de justice tout cela demande que la
vérité soit faite
et tout cela doit passer tout seul doit
avoir lieu
les prisonniers de guerre ont été
évoqués c'est un autre enjeu sur lequel
nous travaillons nos équipes travaillent
sur ce sujet nous devons nous assurer du
fait que nos que nos soldats hommes et
femmes soient bien traités par l'ennemi
il y a certes des organisations
internationales qui s'impliquent dans ce
travail la Croix-Rouge en particulier
afin d'aller dans ce sens et afin
d'avoir accès à nos forces hommes et
femmes prisonniers
dans ce sens afin de faire en sorte que
nos hommes nos femmes nos soldats soient
bien traités
cette année nous avons été en 2022 nous
avons été envahi mais la guerre a
commencé en
2014 des centaines de Tata de Crimée ont
disparu dans quel état sont-ils où
sont-ils sont-ils encore en vie et ainsi
on va t-il de nombreux citoyens
ukrainiens nous avons eu des échanges de
prisonniers il y a eu également des
échanges de prisonniers politiques
un certain nombre de personnes ont
également été
prisonnier pour des raisons politiques
par la Russie où sont-ils actuellement
où sont nos ou sont nos soldats nous ne
le savons pas
le travail de l'OSCE est extrêmement
important sur ce point nous collaborons
régulièrement avec l'OS sur l'ensemble
de ces sujets
nous avons échangé en forme en format
aux différents formats y compris le
format Normandie à l'époque sur
différents anges
nous avons entendu à l'époque
différentes réponses
et j'en ai eu assez qu'on me dise à
l'époque oui ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
notre mandat ça n'est pas notre mandat
nous avons pas demandé universel il n'y
a pas d'organisation par snack qui
s'occupe de tel ou tel sujet concret
mais merci au secrétaire général
écouterrèse d'avoir pris des nouvelles
initiatives oui nous travaillons avec
Monsieur goutterez avec ses équipes
monsieur goutteh est venu ici nous avons
échangé sur les sujets que je suis en
train d'évoquer avec vous
nous avons été capable de mettre en
place un corridor un couloir humanitaire
pour sortir pour
exporter nos céréales
cette guerre montre les faiblesses non
seulement de l'Ukraine mais également
des institutions internationales
elles montrent également les faiblesses
tu continues européen et de l'Union
européenne
comment pouvons-nous changer les
institutions les institutions
internationales à la fin qu'elle soit
qu'elle sorte renforcée il faut une
nouvelle architecture une nouvelle
une réforme des institutions
internationales ça peut aussi être une
victoire de cette guerre
points soulevés sur le fait que la Chine
n'a fait des propositions de paix
nous avons entendu les propositions en
fait par la Chine dans le cadre des
Nations Unies et nous avons également
entendu le fait que la Chine se propose
de fournir
des armes létales à la Russie comment
pouvons-nous influer sur la Chine
il me semble que la Chine
choisit de s'impliquer une
diplomatiquement et à mon avis la Chine
a commencé à s'intéresser aux affaires
du crâne
et j'ai dit que ça ne s'est pas une
chose négative je suis plutôt favorable
cela étant
quel est le sens derrière les mots que
la diplomatie chinoise met dans son plan
de paix nous sommes en guerre
tout le monde dit quelque chose
tout le monde parle
la question c'est de savoir ce qui suit
concrètement quels sont les implications
pour nous
les Chinois parlent de nous
il s'agit d'intégrité territoriale c'est
ça qui est important pour nous
le respect de l'intégrité de le respect
de l'intégrité territoriale
et certes mentionné mais il n'est pas
mentionné de quel pays nous parlons dans
le plan
chinois parlons-nous de l'Ukraine
non je suis déjà bien parle ou bien
parlons-nous d'autre chose quand à la
sécurisation des sites nucléaires cela
reprend les intérêts de l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale il y a
certains points que je trouve
intéressant et certaines idées avec
lesquelles je ne suis pas d'accord ni
probablement d'autres partenaires mais
c'est quand même un début c'est quand
même quelque chose et c'est mieux que
rien
il me semble
que les initiatives
sont vont dans le bon sens car elles
vont dans le sens du droit international
et du principe international le respect
des intégrités territoriales
il faut utiliser ces initiatives
travailler avec les Chinois ensemble
pourquoi pas
notre tâche est d'unir l'ensemble des
pays afin d'unir
la Russie voilà la mission qu'elle a
d'autres tout est bon à prendre dans ce
sens
bonjour monsieur
[Musique]
de quelle mesure votre pays est-il
soutenu par ses partenaires deuxièmement
après la victoire quelle réforme allez
vous mettre en oeuvre en Ukraine
quelle va être votre politique
nationale et international
ce que vous voulez que je fasse un
selfie avec vous très bien
de prendre une photo avec lui merci
pour revenir au soutien de l'Azerbaïdjan
parce que c'est un sac que vous pensez
un journaliste un journaliste
azarbaïdjanais est en mesure de me poser
cette question en ukrainien et bien il
me semble
que c'est déjà une réponse merci pour
votre soutien
quand au président Alif quant aux
autorités politiques nous sommes en
échange avec lui nous le remercions pour
les différents types de soutien qu'il
nous a fournis le président aliyef
respecte la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale c'est le point numéro 1
pour notre pays il est en faveur de
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Ukraine
selon lui l'Ukraine la Crimée pardon
fait partie de l'Ukraine c'était
essentiel pour nous
je respecte je respecte l'expertise de
militaire de ceux qui nous soutiennent
le général Miley
tout dépend sur le point que vous
évoquez du soutien que nous recevons
et bien s'il veut que nous gagnions plus
rapidement
que nous repoussions plus rapidement les
ennemis hors de notre pays doit
nous livrer des hommes plus rapidement
je pense que c'est comme ça
le plus important a été bien sûr la
dernière la récente visite du président
très important surtout les armes mais
nous bénéficions du soutien également
politique du Congrès américain de
bénéficiant du soutien de la société
américaine je vois ce soutien j'ai été à
Washington je l'ai vu de mes propres
yeux j'ai vu les gens avec nos drapeaux
j'ai vu le soutien dans leurs yeux j'ai
vu les drapeaux américains et ukrainiens
côte à côte je connais la force du
soutien
il s'agit également et surtout de la
présence physique des armes sur le
terrain c'est peut-être le plus
important mais également un soutien
financier apporté par les États-Unis les
Américains croient en notre victoire ils
sont optimistes le président Biden est
venu à Kiev c'est un signal très fort le
président le général Mylène n'était pas
présent nous l'inverse
je pense qu'il est très important je
pense qu'il a différents aspects
importants dans votre question
à augmenter leur dépense de sécurité il
y a que le formater
une question complexe de votre part
permettez-moi de vous donner une réponse
complexe le président
la réforme des institutions également
question de l'augmentation des budgets
le crâne
intellectuelle de l'OTAN nous comprenons
des robots
et d'un certain nombre d'avancées je
pense pas uniquement à des projectiles
et à des matériels je pense ici à
l'espace cyber au drone
nous comprenons
pas maintenant
universelle
d'augmenter les défenses les dépenses de
défense il s'agit de réformer
les systèmes de sécurité en général et
je pense le temps est en train de le
faire je pense que c'est une excellente
chose
car nous voyons de quoi nos voisins sont
capables nous voyons de quoi est capable
la Fédération nous aussi
tout le monde veut acheter des armes et
des nouvelles technologies donc il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas quand au
leadership
oh
la Russie est sous son pion la Russie
n'est plus un partenaire économique
attrayants
[Musique]
que la Russie veut que l'on dépense
d'elle veut que l'on dépende de son gaz
afin de vous avoir en son pouvoir
des territoires et pour exercer des
pressions et prendre des mesures
coercitives c'est ce que la Russie a
fait c'est la volonté d'une seule
personne le monde doit comprendre que
nous avons besoin d'être d'une
indépendance concrète
l'indépendance pour l'Ukraine mais
chaque pays en a besoin également
donc ici à la première partie de votre
question
vous avez constaté comme nous les
meurtres les tortures commis par la
Russie le monde entier n'a vu personne
se cache même pas les Russes ne
dissimule même pas leurs exactions ils
traînent des otages il déportent des
enfants ils tirent sur il tire sur nos
centrales nucléaires ils font des
menaces atomiques qu'en est-il des gens
qu'en est-il des gens qui sont massacrés
par la Russie qu'en est-il des enfants
qui sont tenus par les parents et qui
est sur lesquels tout de même
pouvons-nous l'Ukraine nous asseoir et
négocier avec ces gens là
je ne pense pas que ça soit possible et
je ne le veux pas
ici du phénomène 2
en faisant référence aux fascisme
quitter notre pays cesser de le
bombarder cesser de tuer notre
population civile
de détruire notre infrastructure
énergétique notre système
d'approvisionnementaux cesser de
bombarder nos villes de nos villages
cesser les tueries cc
de brûler nos forêts
et ensuite peut-être nous commencerons à
vous dire
comment cette guerre peut être résolue
de manière diplomatique question de la
Ukraine à prava
[Musique]
un an de gars en Ukraine
il est temps de tirer un premier bilan
ma question est peut-être
le président pouvez-vous nous dire
les journées qui ont été les plus
difficiles les journées les nuits qui
ont été les plus difficiles et
deuxièmement quel a été selon vous votre
la pire erreur que vous ayez commise
durant cette guerre troisièmement
vous recommande
qui vous êtes déçu au sein des
personnels de votre équipe durant cette
guerre premier point qui m'a déçu
commençons par là puisque j'ai oublié le
début de la question que vous avez posé
alors qui m'a déçu tous ceux qui
fuit le 24 février tous ceux qui ont
quitté qui aiment tous ceux qui ont
quitté leur poste dans différentes
villes et villages tous ceux qui avaient
des responsabilités tous ceux qui
devaient être un exemple dans nos
communes et qui devaient se battre pour
leur pays tout cela tout cela mon déçu
quant à une erreur que j'ai commise je
ne sais pas peut-être il en a eu
beaucoup je ne peux pas vous dire
précisément jean-commer
probablement chaque jour je travaille
de tôt le matin à tard le soir je prends
des décisions je fais des arbitrages je
suis
je suis un homme normal
je suis en vie même si certains sur
terre aimeraient qu'il en aille
différemment
je sais que je connais des erreurs
j'évite
autant que possible
car je défends mon pays je défends la
Constitution je défonce un constitution
et son intégrité de territoire la
sécurité de nos citoyens
grâce à Dieu j'ai évité les pires
erreurs
sur ces points quant aux journées aux
nuits les plus difficiles
je crois que ça a été
je crois que ça a été ma visite à
ça a été de me rendre sur place lorsque
nous avons libéré cette commune
ce sont probablement les heures les plus
difficiles
nous avons été confrontés au mal pur ou
mal qui était sur Terre et pas seulement
sur terre chez nous dans notre pays
un certain nombre de pays
ne vous ont pas rendu visite comme le
Japon
que peut faire le Japon pour accélérer
son soutien à l'Ukraine
merci pour votre question importante
j'ai échangé avec les membres du G7
l'Ukraine
nous avons échangé quant au soutien sur
le soutien à notre pays
sont en cours le Japon s'implique
fortement dans cette tête le Japon
lui-même énormément avec nous
je tiens à dire que je suis très
reconnaissant à votre premier ministre
c'est un homme très honnête très claire
je le comprends nous le comprenons très
bien
et j'apprécie au début de cette guerre
j'ai appris à connaître la valeur des
hommes la haute valeur des hommes de sa
trempe merci pour le soutien financier
qui est en cours de préparation au
Parlement japonais je me rappelle plus
exactement
fait énormément pour nous
j'ai reçu une communication que j'essaie
sur
j'ai reçu du Range de 7 une
communication du Premier ministre
japonais
nous avons également reçu des
communications par nos canaux
diplomatiques
le Premier ministre
en réponse à notre invitation
il a le premier son japonais a dit qu'il
nous rendrait visite il n'a pas dit
quand c'est un invité un autre que nous
attendons avec beaucoup d'impatience
le Japon
fourni un soutien véritablement crucial
à l'Ukraine
l'Italie également
l'Italie au niveau
l'Italie
au sein de l'Union européenne le Japon
dans le cadre du G7 peut-être
pourrons-nous en parler un petit peu
plus tard c'est un rôle important un
rôle positif et merci pour ce rôle
assumé par le gouvernement japonais
monsieur le président
vous avez été la personne la plus
recherchée mondialement maintenant vous
êtes en mesure de voyager dans le monde
vous donner des conférences de presse
êtes-vous un peu plus en sécurité est-ce
que vous pensez que vous êtes moins
ciblé par Poutine actuellement
et bien je n'ai pas beaucoup
d'informations sur les rêveries sur la
rêverie et les pensées morbides du
président Poutine
mais oui c'est de fait une question qui
se pose
président que dois-je faire je dois
conduire l'état je dois conduire la
nation je dois conduire le peuple
et
je n'ai jamais
pensé
à diminuer l'intensité de l'effort que
je mets dans ma tâche
ma mission principale c'est de garantir
un soutien international à mon pays
est-ce que je le fais bien est-ce que je
ne fais pas bien je ne sais pas en tout
cas je ne le fais pas seul nous
travaillons
en équipe les premiers temps ont été
extrêmement difficiles
le moment était extrêmement grave
puisque c'est à ce moment là que les
mécanismes se mettent en place
nous avons dû expliquer à nos
partenaires que nous avions besoin des
armes pour défendre nos vies et défendre
notre pays puis la fatigue une fatigue
profonde s'est installée mais enfin
tout le monde
a ses valeurs ces problèmes c'est
convictions nous savons qu'elles sont
les enjeux dans les pays qui nous
soutiennent nous connaissons la prix la
crise des prix de la vie dans les pays
qui nous soutiennent nous savons que la
situation alimentaire dans un sens dans
un certain nombre de pays
chacun doit assumer ses propres
responsabilités nous avons que nous
soutenir coûte mais nous soutenir paye
c'est aussi le message que je veux
passer
il faut donc dire à tout le monde à
toutes les familles à tous les citoyens
que cette guerre n'est pas que la nôtre
que nous battons pour eux tous cette
guerre a provoqué toutes les crises que
j'ai évoqué c'est la guerre qui provoque
les crises c'est les Russes qui
provoquent toutes les crises que
subissent un certain nombre de pays
c'est l'Ukraine c'est la Russie qui a
voulu détruire l'Ukraine et qui affirme
que ensuite que c'est notre faute alors
que la responsabilité est entièrement de
son côté
c'est ce que nous tentons d'expliquer
moi mes équipes mes ministres
le gouvernement le Parlement tout le
monde est impliqué dans ce travail de
conviction
c'est un moment ont été cruciaux ce
moment ont été extrêmement importants
et puis c'est bien les moments où il
faut savoir dire merci dire merci au
monde merci de ne pas nous avoir
abandonné ni laisser dans la détresse
merci de ne pas nous avoir
merci d'avoir agi lorsque nous étions
lorsque nous étions dans le plus grand
des besoins
et nous savons quels sont les effets
dans les pays qui nous ont soutenus
merci merci du fond du coeur à tous ceux
qui nous ont soutenus ils ont fait
beaucoup j'ignore
combien de personnes ont souffert en
raison du soutien qui nous a été apporté
mais je les remercie merci en
particulier à l'Allemagne
si pour le soutien financier et pour les
blancs et je sais que ça a des plus au
sein de la sorcière allemande mais
le gouvernement allemand la tout de même
fait
il s'agit maintenant d'ouvrir une
nouvelle page
dans notre défense il s'agit nous avons
besoin de davantage de soutien nous
avons besoin de munitions
et de leur demander
merci monsieur le président
le président Emmanuel Macron
a dit il y a quelques jours qu'il
voulait la victoire de l'Ukraine mais
sans écraser la Russie
pensez-vous que cela est compatible avec
la victoire de l'Ukraine et si vous me
permettez une deuxième question
vous avez parlé de ce qui était le plus
difficile quel a été la victoire l'aquit
dont vous êtes le plus fier au cours de
cette année de guerre
a évoqué ce qui allait se passer après
la défaite
il est utile de commencer à réfléchir ce
qui va se passer après la défaite de
Moscou
un certain nombre de leaders et de
société
atmosphère
en tout cas
pensent que l'Ukraine sera victorieuse
ça signifie
ce sont les conclusions
qu'ils tirent de la situation actuelle
et les dynamiques actuelles
quant à ce qui va se passer avec la
Russie après et en Russie oui je vais je
vais vous dire ce que je vais vous dire
honnêtement que je m'en fiche
complètement ce qui se passe en Russie
ne m'intéresse pas c'est le fond c'est
la responsabilité des Russes que de s'en
occuper si les Russes avaient réfléchi à
ce qui se passerait avec leur pays
n'en serions pas là si les Russes
avaient travaillé à l'heure
liberté d'expression à leur liberté dans
différents domaines nous en serions pas
là ce ne serait pas un pays
opprimé par un régime la Russie est un
pays riche qui a été pillée et opprimé
aux mains d'une caste dirigeant
nous ne réfléchissons pas ce qui va se
passer en Russie nous pensons à
nous-mêmes nous voulons nous libérer et
vivre paisiblement ensuite
nos propres problèmes nous avons
traversé
cette crise là et ensuite chercher à
vivre pour chacun doit s'occuper de son
propre pays il y a certains pays qui
sont par nature
agressifs mais il ferait mieux de
s'occuper de leur avenir plutôt que
d'agresser leurs voisins
donc
chacun des dirigeants politiques de
l'Union européenne
sur la question mais côté russe il y a
un certain nombre de membres de l'élite
qui sont en grande difficulté
en Europe ou dans le monde aurait été
confisqué ils sont dans une situation
très difficile ces gens ces oligarques
ne sont pas satisfaits leurs enfants
étudiés à l'étranger
c'était l'endroit mais la situation
est devenue très difficile pour eux car
leur confort ça aurait été vu considérer
considérablement réduit
tout ce qu'il en reste c'est la Russie
pensez-vous
[Musique]
se satisface
en Russie
tout a été bloqué pour à l'étranger
gardez leur capitaux en Russie où vous
t-il chercher à l'avenir à reprendre
leur bien à l'étranger
si on lui confie que c'est bien
elle commencera à réfléchir à ce qu'il
faut faire chez elle
elle commencera à réfléchir à ce
agir apprendre des mesures au niveau
politique et peut-être même cela
terminera t-il
à la table négociation en termes
favorable pour nous
[Musique]
avons tous été choqués par
l'agression de la Russie
nous avons tous appelé nous nous en
avons tous appelé à nos partenaires
internationaux pour qu'ils nous
des avions ou pour qu'ils mettent en
place une zone d'interdiction aérienne
il a eu ensuite plus tard l'affaire
des léopards qui nous ont une été
fournis et puis nous sommes maintenant
dans la phase des avions il y a quelques
semaines le président Biden a expliqué
qu'il ne donnerait pas d'avion à
l'Ukraine d'autres d'autres ministres
d'autres leaders européens ont expliqué
qu'il y avait une décision sur ce point
avec la décision finale sera favorable à
l'Ukraine à Genève pouvons nous
expliquer où en est le dossier ds16
allons-nous finir par en avoir ou bien
d'autres avions quelle est la situation
sur ce point
je voulais juste revenir sur la question
précédente de françaises
sur
la victoire la plus importante sur la
victoire qui dont j'étais plus fier je
vais vous dire je l'attends cette
journée c'est ce sera la journée de la
victoire pour revenir à la question qui
venait de poser sur l'armement oui au
début c'est toujours comme ça
différentes armes différents systèmes
d'armes de l'OTAN nous sont d'abord dans
un premier temps refusé nous les avons
pas nous tentons les obtenir et on ne
les refuse
nous sommes en effet pas des membres de
cette alliance nous travaillons
et nous obtenons
que nous demandons d'abord les les
canons de 155 mm puis il est à mars cela
a ouvert un nouveau chapitre de cette
guerre quand la livraison des armements
chapitre qui se concluera par notre
victoire
fonctionnent très bien et nous
permettront d'aller d'avancer dans le
bon sens quand au véhicules le blindait
le combat d’infanterie ces équipements
sont très importants pour
protéger pour donner de la protection de
soldats sur son bataille et les blindés
les temps lourds sont importants pour
passer à l'offensive pendant longtemps
on n'a pas voulu entendre parler de ces
blindés lourds et puis à un moment donné
la situation s'est débloquer nous avons
su trouver les arguments pour convaincre
l'argument le plus important sans doute
c'est le fait que nous soyons en eux que
nous soyons en mesure de montrer que
nous savons gagner que nous savons
libéré nos territoires et que nous
savons remporté des batailles nous
l'avons fait nous avons remporté de
grandes victoires à car kiffe is Youm à
Carson autant de jalons très important
sur notre parcours
c'est un cercle vertueux plus nous
gagnons plus on nous donne d'armes et
plus on nous donne d'armes plus nous
remportons de bataille
nous avons également ouvert le chef
ouvert un chapitre celui des missiles
entériens patriotes nous sommes
maintenant également en train d'écrire
le chapitre des blancs des lourds
léopard et c'est une très bonne chose
je tiens à assister sur la nécessité que
c'est que les armes en premier soit
livrés le plus rapidement possible car
c'est car le retard accumulé et rattrapé
par la mécanienne avec le sang de ses
soldats
sont particulièrement importants et nous
permettent de protéger notre pays il
nous permettent de combattre les drones
et les missiles de l'ennemi
d'autres armements qui sont qui jouent
un rôle important pour nous comme par
exemple ceux que nous utilisons dans nos
opérations maritimes
l'importance particulière de nos armes
entièrement pour la défense de notre
pays c'est dans ce sens que j'ai
rencontré le Premier ministre
britannique
et dans le cadre de cet échange nous
avons également discuté de l'opportunité
de livrer des avions occidentaux
les Britanniques vont former nos Pilates
dont vont commencer par former nos
premières étapes j'ai également par le
Premier ministre au Premier ministre
polonais la Pologne va commencer à
former des pilotes
Ukrainiens à piloter des F16 nous sommes
en conversation avec nos différents
partenaires sur cet enjeu et nous avons
le sentiment que les choses bougent je
ne veux pas parler des trois autres pays
européens qui ont évoqué la possibilité
de nous de former nos pilotes et de nous
livrer des avions de combat vous
comprenez que je dois être
confidentielles sur ce sujet
je veux insister sur la rapidité
tout ça c'est pour nous crucial pour
nous